[Música]
el presidente francés emmanuel macrón
anunció nuevas restricciones para
enfrentar una posible cuarta ola de
contagios y muertes por como el 19 en el
país a causa de la variante delta entre
las medidas anunció la vacunación
obligatoria para el personal de salud y
el pase sanitario en establecimientos
públicos adicionales tenemos reportes
a las multitudinarias protestas que
tuvieron lugar este domingo en varias
ciudades de cuba al presidente de eeuu
joe biden
exigió al gobierno de la isla que se
abstenga a ejercer la violencia contra
la ciudadanía por su parte presidente
cubano miguel díaz canel insistió en que
la crisis nacional se debe al bloqueo
económico estadounidense tenemos
análisis
y el festival de cine de cannes vivió
hoy unas sus jornadas más concurridas en
torno a dos estrenos internacionales las
cintas del estadounidense wes anderson y
del ruso kirill cierren y que
participaron en la competencia oficial
además de ser el colombiano simón mesa
con su filme hampa
actualizamos la información de américa
latina y el mundo aquí entra el 24
bienvenidos de nuevo yo soy liliana
valencia iniciamos en francia donde el
presidente emmanuel macrón hizo varios
anuncios para contrarrestar una posible
cuarta ola de contagios porque 19 el
mandatario anunció la vacunación que
ésta será obligatoria para el personal
de salud y que desde el 21 de julio el
pase de vacunación que era requerido
únicamente en eventos masivos tendrá que
presentarse en escenarios culturales y
lugares como cafés restaurantes centros
comerciales y aviones también y trenes
para recorridos de larga distancia desde
parís diosa periodista natalia ruiz no
se entregó previamente los detalles
emanuel mcconnell eligió a la torre
eiffel como telón de fondo para
dirigirse a los franceses en un discurso
más bien esperanzador en el que trató de
explicar que tanto el fin de la epidemia
como la reactivación económica van de la
mano
francia se enfrenta a una nueva ola de
contagios debido a la variante delta y
por eso hay que tomar nuevas medidas por
ahora lo que el presidente quiere es que
durante este verano se intensifique la
campaña de vacunación y de hecho ésta
será obligada
para el personal sanitario tiene hasta
el 15 de septiembre para vacunarse y a
partir de ese momento habrá controles y
sanciones además de esto se generaliza
el pase sanitario será obligatorio para
ingresar a cualquiera lugar cultural y a
partir de agosto si usted quiere ir a un
bar a un restaurante al hospital o hacer
un viaje largo ya sea en avión o en tren
también la tendrá que presentar este
pase esto es incluso válido para el
personal además de esto habrá un control
mucho más fuerte de las fronteras y las
personas no vacunadas que quieran
ingresar a francia tendrán que pasar una
cuarentena obligatoria en manuela como
hablo bastante de la economía tratando
de proyectarse en el futuro al futuro
sobre todo que le quedan 10 meses de su
mandato y bueno habló de las buenas
cifras del empleo de el 6% de
crecimiento económico que se espera para
este 2021 en el país y también la
necesidad de reformas en especial de esa
reforma pensional pero dijo que ésta
únicamente va a adelantarse si el país
logra controlar la epidemia
miles de cubanos salieron a las calles
de las principales ciudades este domingo
para pronunciarse contra la falta de
alimentos y medicinas los apagones de
luz la represión y las medidas
económicas del gobierno el presidente
miguel díaz canel acusó el lunes al
gobierno de eeuu de estar detrás de las
protestas y washington por su parte
exigió que no se use la violencia contra
los manifestantes en europea por su
parte llamó a la calma veamos el informe
cuba acusa a washington de estar detrás
de las protestas el presidente miquel
díaz canel respondió a los reclamos
contra la grave crisis humanitaria y
sanitaria que atraviesa el país culpando
al embargo comercial estadounidense que
pesa sobre el aislante todos estos
procesos que hemos tratado enfrentar y
de vencer ante una política de asfixia
económica para provocar estallidos
sociales en el país
joseph e efectos acumulativos y
precisamente yo creo que hoy los
problemas que tenemos tienen que ver con
esos efectos acumulativos las medidas
impuestas por el gobierno de eeuu
restringen la compra y venta de
mercancías desde y hacia cuba sin
embargo el gobierno estadounidense
rechazó las acusaciones y volví
y sería un grave error por parte del
régimen cubano interpretar lo que está
ocurriendo en decenas de ciudades a lo
largo de la isla como resultado de
cualquier acción de eeuu
con el tono que compartió la unión
europea que pidió a las autoridades
cubanas que escuchen el descontento de
los manifestantes la organización de los
estados americanos y la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos
también alzaron sus voces a favor del
derecho de los cubanos a protestar solo
el presidente mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador rechazó cualquier enfoque
intervencionista la verdad es que
si se quisiera ayudar a cuba
lo primero que se debería hacer
y suspender el bloqueo por su parte el
líder de brasil
jair bolsonaro aprovechó la crisis en la
isla caribeña para compararla con la
situación de venezuela y advertir sobre
el socialismo
el opositor venezolano juan guaidó
denunció persecución por parte de las
autoridades la esposa del líder político
fabiana rosales había denunciado que
agentes del grupo élite faes de la
policía había hecho presencia en el
domicilio para arrestarlo lo que guay lo
calificó como un intento de secuestro
luego de la de luego de que la policía
de haití anunciara la detención de uno
de los presuntos autores intelectuales
del asesinato del presidente joven él
moix las autoridades colombianas se
entregaron nuevos detalles de sus
investigaciones fueron identificados los
colombianos 18 capturados y 3 muertos
que supuestamente estuvieron implicados
en el magnicidio y es que este lunes la
fiscalía de puerto príncipe la capital
haitiana comenzó las tareas de
interrogatorio
en noticias del continente africano
hablamos de sudáfrica porque hay tiendas
saqueadas autopistas bloqueadas y
manifestantes con paros marchando por
las calles de johannesburgo es la
situación en este país austral del
continente africano después de la
violencia tras el encarcelamiento del ex
presidente sudafricano jacob zuma la
violencia deja al menos 6 muertos y más
de 200 detenidos
violencia saqueos y decenas de
detenciones
la ira aumentó entre los partidarios del
ex presidente jacob zuma después de su
ingreso en prisión el pasado jueves los
disturbios se produjeron principalmente
en la provincia de wallace hulu natal
pedimos que el señor zuma reciba un
indulto presidencial especial con
carácter de urgencia para que sudáfrica
pueda estabilizarse esta situación no es
agradable ni correcta
cientos de personas desafiaron las
restricciones por el coronavirus en
johannesburgo en la provincia de wat en
allí la policía también realizó
detenciones y el tráfico se paralizó en
una de las principales autopistas cerca
de la prisión donde está recluido suma
esto después de que se incendiaran
camiones
pero los camiones han estado ardiendo
desde que llegue la policía bloqueó los
camiones por un lado pero los
manifestantes vinieron de otra dirección
y siguieron quemando baches aunque la
atención parece haber sido provocada por
la detención de zuma condenado a 15
meses de prisión por desacato al
tribunal las protestas están también
relacionadas con las dificultades
económicas para que sudáfrica frente a
fuertes restricciones bajo una tercera
ola del brote de kobe 19
no toleraremos ningún tipo de actos
criminales no toleraremos los actos de
vandalismo aquellos que están envueltos
en los actos de violencia serán
detenidos y judicializados
el gobierno ordenó el despliegue de
tropas en las provincias afectadas por
los disturbios dijo que las mantendrá
dependiendo de la situación en el
terreno
zuma se ha negado a cooperar con un
equipo de que investiga la corrupción
durante su tiempo en el poder a la voz
de festival de cine de cannes cuya
versión número 74 avanza yo vi si vivió
una de las jornadas más concurridas del
encuentro detalles con nuestra enviada
especial eric olavarría
bill murray tilda swinton adrian brody
owen wilson benicio del toro la alfombra
roja este festival de cannes se llenó
esta noche de estrellas de hollywood con
el estreno internacional y además en la
competencia oficial del festival de
cannes de the french dispatch la última
película del estadounidense wes anderson
quizás hasta ahora la película más
esperada de este festival nunca fue tan
difícil encontrar entradas para la
prensa y los críticos y hoy vimos muchos
festivaleros con letreros pidiendo una
invitación para alguna de las
proyecciones de esta película sino hoy
también pudimos ver en este festival de
cannes pero a través del vídeo llamada
adquirir serebrenik o el director ruso
recordamos que no puede salir de su país
porque allí fue condenado por
malversación de fondos públicos su
película la fiebre de petro fue muy bien
recibida por el público del festival de
cannes él lo pudo ver a través de esta
vídeo llamada cuenta la historia de un
hombre que confunde debido a una fiebre
el pasado el presente
- lineal que le toqué presentó aquí en
el 2018 pero con una puesta en escena
igual de teatral y con una excelente
banda sonora
así finalizamos con tu nombre con más
sombras el 24 punto com
[Música]